[Applaudissements]
je m'appelle Yann grand Guillaume et je
suis joueur de tennis fauteuil
oui oui vous avez bien entendu je joue
au tennis en fauteuil
et d'ailleurs
j'ai un objectif
les Jeux paralympiques de 2028 à Los
Angeles
incroyable non
je vous entends déjà vous dire mais
comment en est-il arrivé là
pour vous répondre je vais vous raconter
qui j'étais avant
avant le 29 septembre 2019
j'ai toujours été un garçon timide
réservé et pas du tout sur de lui
un garçon qui prenait aucune décision
importante et qui se contentait de son
quotidien banal
j'avais des semaines toutes tracées
j'allais au travail du lundi au vendredi
avec des horaires fixes
et je faisais du sport le weekend
j'avais des sorties en famille entre
potes
et le foot le dimanche
on est d'accord rien d'exceptionnel
mais alors pourquoi est-ce que je vous
raconte ça
parce que je crois que c'est important
pour le reste de l'histoire
au lycée j'étais le premier à me cacher
à me faire tout petit pour ne pas passer
à l'oral devant les profs ou le jury
j'étais très stressé un peu comme ce
soir
et j'avais très peur de ce que l'on
dirait de moi
aujourd'hui je suis handicapé
en fauteuil roulant
et j'ai beaucoup moins peur du candidate
handicapé oui
ces mots sur le papier
un simple mot puisque personnellement je
me sens pas plus handicapé que des
personnes dites valides alors comment je
suis passé de ma vie d'avant ma vie
banale à ma vie d'aujourd'hui et à ce
challenge des Jeux paralympiques de 2028
bon
il va falloir que je vous parle de
l'accident
le dimanche 29 septembre 2019
j'ai eu un accident de voiture au retour
d'un match de football avec quatre
autres coéquipiers
oui avant je joue au foot pas au tennis
et d'ailleurs j'ai pensé que les tennis
n'était pas un sport fait pour moi
ce dimanche 29 septembre il pleut des
trombes d'eau non-stop
en arrivant au stade le coach nous donne
la composition de l'équipe et je suis
sur le banc des remplaçants
il faut savoir que depuis la reprise au
mois de juillet je suis titulaire à tous
les matchs de l'équipe première
alors forcément ce jour là je suis un
peu frustré
mais j'ai pas le choix j'accepte les
choix du coach
je joue 20 minutes je fais une mauvaise
entrée en jeu et nous perdons le match
bref
un dimanche compliqué
sans compter la suite
la suite c'est l'accident de voiture sur
la route du retour
le conducteur perd le contrôle sur une
petite route de forêt trempée
dans la voiture je suis à l'arrière à
gauche
j'ai pris la même place que sur le
terrain où j'étais latéral gauche
je suis en train d'écrire un SMS à ma
femme Apolline
j'ai qu'une seule hâte rentrer à la
maison retrouver Pauline mes animaux et
oubliez ce dimanche catastrophique
et puis d'un coup
tout va très vite
j'entends quelqu'un dans la voiture
crier attention
la voiture glisse je sens un énorme choc
et puis plus rien
blackout
quand je me réveille je suis encore dans
la voiture il reste que le conducteur
est moins à l'intérieur
toutes les vitres de la voiture sont
explosées
il y a du sang partout
et je vois le conducteur tête en bas
rempli de ça
mon premier réflexe est alors de sortir
de la voiture pour aller l'aider
j'essaie de me hisser pour sortir
mais impossible de bouger les jambes
elle ne répond plus
je ne sens plus rien
la panique prend alors le dessus et je
me mets à hurler que je ne sens plus mes
jambes
le moment le plus horrible de ma courte
vie
vraiment je me sens partir
j'ai l'impression de mourir
mes blessures sont beaucoup trop graves
pour être soignées de l'hôpital le plus
proche alors je serai transporté à Tours
je serai opéré dans la nuit du dimanche
au lundi
et le lundi matin le verdict tombe
le chirurgien qui m'a opéré rentre dans
ma chambre
m'explique que je suis paraplégique et
que je ne pourrais plus jamais remarcher
de ma vie
il m'explique que pendant l'accident une
vertèbre s'est cassée et venue
sectionner ma moelle épinière
il reste 5 minutes
et je ne le reverrai plus jamais
paraplégique
mais qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
j'ai jamais entendu ce mot de ma vie
mais je comprends rapidement que c'est
très grave et que ma vie ne sera plus
jamais la même
alors à ce moment-là dans ma tête c'est
les montagnes russes entre l'envie de me
battre pour remarcher et l'envie de tout
abandonner
avant je n'ai pas ou très peu côtoyé de
personnes handicapées et j'en ai une
mauvaise image
j'en ai une image de personne assistée
et c'est pas possible pour moi j'ai
besoin de ma liberté
mais assister je l'ai été pendant
plusieurs semaines au centre de
rééducation j'ai dû rester allongé sur
le dos pendant 45 jours
45 jours allongé
sur le dos
vous imaginez
je ne pouvais presque pas bouger je ne
pouvais pas me doucher ni m'habiller
seul
c'était horrible
et c'est 45 jours ont été les plus longs
et les plus instructifs en 29 ans de vie
parce que j'ai énormément appris sur moi
et c'est pendant cette période que je me
suis fixé un objectif
de ne pas lâcher
et de remarcher
dans ma vie d'avant j'avais toujours
fait du sport
j'ai fait du rugby pendant 7 ans et puis
du foot pendant 14 ans je faisais aussi
de la course à pied la musculation et
des sorties en VTT
mais je m'étais jamais fixé de gros
challenge sportifs comme faire un Iron
Man ou un marathon par exemple
je me contentais d'être régulier au foot
et de courir au moins 10 km par semaine
normalement quoi
au rugby j'ai toujours été le plus petit
et le plus maigre mais je me défilais
jamais
au foot je faisais souvent partie des
gabarits les plus petits mais j'étais
pas le dernier aller au contact
quand je courais si je m'étais fixé un
objectif de courir 10 km et qu'au bout
de 7 km j'étais fatigué je continuais
parce que c'était hors de question
d'abandonner j'ai toujours eu cet état
d'esprit depuis tout petit
c'est sport m'ont forgé et je suis
persuadé que ça m'a aidé à me dépasser
au centre de rééducation parce que
contrairement à quelqu'un qui n'a jamais
fait de sport je connaissais déjà mon
corps je connaissais mes limites mais
surtout mes capacités physiques un jour
au centre de rééducation mon kiné me
fait faire un exercice pour me relever
du sol en cas de chute
je me tiens alors assez facilement dans
la position du 4 pattes vous savez un
petit peu comme un bébé
il me dit alors que c'est génial et
qu'il y a quelque chose à bosser
alors à partir de ce moment-là
l'objectif c'est de réussir à avancer à
quatre pattes
on a continué à travailler dans cette
position et la toute première fois que
j'ai avancé un genou je l'ai avancé de
quelques centimètres seulement
j'ai retrouvé la possibilité
de faire des mouvements dans des zones
qui devaient être paralysées à la base
première victoire
et puis on a continué jusqu'à ce que je
sois très à l'aise au sol à enchaîner
les allers-retours
et j'ai pu me mettre debout entre les
barres parallèles
nouvelle victoire
à ce moment-là je travaille très dur je
veux avancer entre les barres parallèles
le soir je suis exténué
quand je me couche je hurle de douleur
dans mon lit
j'ai terriblement mal partout mais je
progresse
alors le médecin est satisfait du
résultat et autorise mon kiné
à continuer les exercices debout avec
moi il me fabrique alors des orthèses en
plâtre pour m'aider à progresser le
temps passe et les semaines à travailler
la marche sont bénéfique
j'enchaîne les centaines d'aller-retours
entre les bars parallèles mais j'en veux
toujours plus je demande à sortir des
barres parallèles
alors là mon kiné me propose un
déambulateur
sauf qu'à ce moment là j'ai 30 ans et
j'avoue que c'est un petit peu dur à
encaisser
mais c'est pour la bonne cause alors
j'accepte
et mes premiers pas en déambulateur je
me rappellerai toute ma vie c'était le
23 décembre 2020 entre deux confinement
au centre de rééducation
ce jour-là je marche 30 mètres
c'est ridicule pour un mec qui passait
son temps à marcher et à courir un an
plus tôt
mais croyez-moi c'est exceptionnel parce
qu'un paraplégique qui remarche on
n'envoie pas tous les jours
alors oui avec un déambulateur et des
orthèses mais je le fais je suis
tellement heureux
c'est le feu d'artifice dans ma tête
mais le soir dans mon lit
c'est la catastrophe mon corps est en
mille morceaux encore une fois mais je
ne dis rien et j'encaisse les semaines
passent et chaque jour est différent
un jour je progresse et le lendemain je
repars presque de zéro le TOC mon corps
s'adapte à cette dépense d'énergie c'est
long beaucoup trop long pour moi
mais je progresserai quand même
jusqu'à marcher
sans 2 M
le jour de ma sortie du centre de
rééducation le 29 janvier 2021 après un
an et quatre mois
sans 2 M
c'est l'Everest pour un mec qui est
censé être paralysé des jambes quand
même j'ai travaillé comme un achat
et je sais que cette période a été
bénéfique dans l'évolution de mon
mentale
tous les jours vraiment tous les jours
ont été extrêmement difficiles mais je
n'ai jamais abandonné pendant mon séjour
au centre de rééducation je me suis
inscrit à des détections paralympiques
qui ont pour but de trouver les nouveaux
athlètes paralympiques de demain
120 athlètes se sont inscrits mais
seulement 30 ont été retenus sur toute
la France et j'en faisais partie
le jour J j'ai eu de nombreux tests
physiques à faire et j'ai fait de bons
résultats
sur cette sport représentés j'ai été
retenu quatre fois
j'ai donc eu des entretiens individuels
avec 4 représentants ceux du volley
assis du badminton du pôle handisport et
du tennis fauteuil
dès le début de mon contact avec la
représentante du tennis un crush sportif
a eu lieu
elle me dit
j'ai l'impression que tu es prêt
physiquement
alors là je lui ai dit je suis pas venu
en touriste j'ai travaillé pour réussir
ses tests j'étais donc prêt
elle a aimé mon implication et me
propose de rejoindre le tennis
elle m'avait donc à venir voir une
compétition de tennis un mois après j'y
vais je la revois sur place et à la fin
de la journée elle me propose de tester
le tennis fauteuil sauf que j'ai jamais
joué au tennis de ma vie
au jour 45 minutes et elle me dit que
j'ai du potentiel et qu'elle me
recontactera un mois plus tard elle
m'invite à un stage de tennis de 3 jours
un régal
cette fois-ci c'est sûr
je veux continuer à pas à tennis tout
est allé très vite en juin 2021 je
faisais les détections et en août 2021
je faisais mon premier stage de tennis
alors je vais au Para tennis c'est bien
mais avec quel objectif
si j'ai fait ces détections c'est pas
pour rien je veux tout faire pour
atteindre les Jeux paralympiques de 2028
à Los Angeles
alors vous vous dites peut-être et
pourquoi pas Paris 2024 c'est un peu à
la mode en ce moment
l'objectif pour 2028 est déjà énorme il
faut pas brûler les étapes
2024 c'est demain et je serai jamais
prêt j'aurai jamais le niveau
pour atteindre mon objectif il me faudra
énormément de travail à l'entraînement
de la rigueur de la patience et bien sûr
des résultats en compétition des
compétitions nationales mais aussi
internationales
d'ailleurs
j'ai commencé par des compétitions
régionales en mars 2022 et je débute
bien avec plusieurs troisième place
jusqu'en juillet 2022 où je suis convié
à ma première compétition de niveau
national
j'enchaîne les compétitions nationales
un peu partout en France de juillet à
octobre 2022
et puis en novembre 2022 je reçois une
why card une invitation pour mon tout
premier tournoi de tennis de niveau
international en France
c'est incroyable
dites-vous que trois ans plus tôt je
donnais pas rappelé
et aujourd'hui
je fais une compétition de tennis de
niveau international
hallucinant
aujourd'hui je suis 63e joueur français
sur 190 après un petit peu plus d'un an
de compétition nationale pour faire
partie des joueurs sélectionnables pour
les Jeux paralympiques de 2028 je
devrais être dans le top 10 français et
avoir un bon classement international en
2027 2028
vous comprenez maintenant pourquoi Paris
2024 c'est trop tôt
aujourd'hui je progresse bien et je
prends beaucoup de plaisir tout en
restant compétiteur que j'ai toujours
été le sport m'a toujours aidé et je
sais que sans lui je ne serai pas devant
vous aujourd'hui
je me serais pas battu au centre de
rééducation
je n'aurais jamais fait de détection
paralympique et je n'aurais aucune
ambition sportive de haut niveau c'est
en grande partie grâce à lui que j'ai
réussi à accepter mon handicap c'est une
revanche sur ma vie d'avant je me disais
toujours que je n'avais rien à perdre
alors qu'aujourd'hui
je me dis que j'ai tout à gagner
vous vous rappelez tout à l'heure quand
je vous disais que je me cachais pour
pas passer à l'oral au lycée
et là aujourd'hui
je suis en train de faire un TEDx devant
vous
j'ai tout gagné
merci
j'ai volontairement attendu la fin pour
vous le dire et ça va peut-être vous
paraître bizarre
mais je peux vous dire que je suis plus
heureux et plus épanoui
aujourd'hui en fauteuil roulant
qui hier en étant debout
merci beaucoup
merci merci beaucoup